i went full mad scientist in my shop for
uh yeah it was a couple weeks
mike schultz is a two-time paralympic
snowboarder for team usa and also the
ceo and founder of biodapt
i have no experience running a business
i mean i'm a shop guy and an athlete but
i i believed in in what i created so
i started my company biodopt in 2010
um with the intent of designing and
manufacturing the highest performance
lower limb prosthetic equipment for
action sports
i started racing motocross in
1997.
for you young ones watching here yeah
1997.
my professional athletic career has been
quite an adventure it all started in
2003 i turned pro snow cross i was uh
you know banging bars with the best the
best in the world there i've become
monster mike and i like it it fits it
rolls off the talk real good
[Music]
in december of 2008 mike was in an
accident during a snowmobile competition
but his journey was just beginning
yeah i look at it very basic like
yup i got injured i had to have my leg
removed from from the knee down and now
i just need a prosthetic leg to fill
that gap simple as that
mike harness his passion for creating
things to build his very own prosthetic
leg and he turned it into a business
with support from his wife
he didn't want to just sit around he
wanted to live life and get out and do
the things that he loved to do
and through that it's created our new
product and now we're helping others
along the way
for me sport
adaptive sport was so incredibly
important for me to to keep my eyes
looking forward instead of being worried
about what i couldn't do i was more
questioning
how can i
i searched different equipment available
and i just couldn't find any sport
equipment that would perform the way i
thought it should and
and i'm like well
i know i know suspension components i
know shocks you know from my motocross
bikes and snowmobiles and it was like i
got it this is gonna work and i i
went for that first ride and just twist
the grip flew down the rough trail and i
was able to stand up and i just had the
biggest smile on my face
his own determination to find a better
way meant mike could now help other
athletes too
the high majority of all the lower limb
amputee snowboarders
competitors are using biodepth equipment
that i built right here in my shop very
rewarding to help a lot of other
athletes achieve their
their paralympic goals
[Music]